bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat mardi 16 juillet la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale sur le
rôle des banques dans l'évasion fiscale
a poursuivi ses auditions les sénateurs
ont entendu hervé falciani un ancien
informaticien de la banque suisse hsbc
je vous rappelle que le parquet de paris
a ouvert une information judiciaire sur
les conditions dans lesquelles est bien
des milliers de contribuables français
ont ouvert des comptes non déclarés en
suisse chez hsbc
cette découverte a été rendue possible
par la saisie de fichiers codés en 2009
au domicile d'hervé falciani
depuis la suisse l'accusent de vol et
demandent son extradition il vit
actuellement en france sous protection
policière
je vous propose donc ce matin de suivre
son audition suivie de celle de
jean-claude trichet le gouverneur de la
banque de france bonne matinée a tous
bien mes chers collègues nous commençons
cette après midi par l'audition de
monsieur hervé falciani ancien cadre
informaticien de la banque hsbc
je vais commencer par un usage y
connaîtra également maintenant pour vous
qui consiste dans la prestation de
serment
alors vous devez vous vous levez
monsieur monsieur hervé falciani prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité
veuillez levé la main droite et dear
john gurr jeu je vous en remercie je
vous propose mes chers collègues
collègues rapporteur que nous passions
directement puisque c'est désormais un
sujet que si nous ne le maîtrisons pas
totalement et en connaissant tout de
même un certain nombre de contours que
le rapporteur éric bocquet passe
immédiatement aux questions ce qui nous
donnera puisque nous avons une audition
qui se terminera d'environ une heure
plus le temps du débat des questions et
des échanges la parole est à vous le
rapporteur
et à merci monsieur le président
remercie monsieur phacélie d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous avez été
auditionné je crois par l'assemblée
nationale dont vous êtes très sollicité
et pour cause depuis de nombreux mois
voire des années et depuis cette fameuse
affaire que l'on appelle hsbc les
fichiers à l'origine de la publication
desquels vous êtes et donc c'est ce qui
nous amène bien sûr à vous entendre dans
cette commission denquête dont vous
savez quelle qu'elle a très très
particulièrement au rôle des banques et
des acteurs financiers dans le système
de l'évasion fiscale sur lequel nous
avions déjà travaillé l'an dernier est
l'occasion d'une première commission
denquête mais le sujet est tellement
immense complexe voire infinie que nous
creusons notre sillon sur le sujet en
vue bien sûr de formuler des
propositions puisque c'est le le rôle
cette commission denquête l'euro les
parlementaires de au terme de ce travail
d enquête de formuler des propositions
concrètes qui peuvent devenir des lois
de la réglementation pour essayer de
sortir de cette situation dont il est
question régulièrement dans les médias
et je pense qu'il faut s'en féliciter
donc voilà donc c'est à ce titre là que
nous allons vous entendre et dans un
premier temps à une première question
pour poser un peu le planter un peu le
décor d' sur le sujet qui vous concerne
je vois ça va dans quelles conditions
exactement
vous avez été amené à soupçonner que les
fichiers les fichiers hsbc pour faire
simple auquel vous avez eu accès et dans
quelles conditions cet accès vous at il
été proposés contenait des preuves de
transferts illicites pour la première
question introductive si vous voulez
bien sur laquelle j'aimerais vous
entendre
merci merci à vous déjà de me recevoir
et de me donner l'occasion de partager
les éléments qui relèvent de la
préservation des intérêts fondamentaux
et ce qui m'a fait avancer vers la
justice et pour pour le faire de façon
consistante récupérer récolté un
ensemble de preuves à même de supporter
ce que je comptais bien dénoncer au plus
haut niveau
donc ce qui m'a fait prendre cette cette
position ce qui m'a fait entreprendre
cette démarche fut le fait de constater
que la banque est une des premières
banques mondiales qui avaient pour
charge à l'origine de de protéger les
intérêts des clients et aussi ses
engagements au niveau de la société et
donc des états avait en fait pour seule
intention de se soustraire à ses
obligations et d'être dans une logique
de contournement de ses obligations et
de ses responsabilités c'est-à-dire au
lieu d'y faire face
s'assurer de ne pouvoir comment dire il
y s'y retrouver si retrouvé confronté et
ça passait donc par effectivement des
manquements en termes de régulation en
termes de contrôle au niveau du coeur de
ce qu'est l'activité bancaire et
financière aujourd'hui c'est à dire au
niveau de la maîtrise de ces outils
informatiques
donc comment ai-je pu récolter ses
preuves
eh bien je l' ai pu le faire que par
l'intermédiaire de personnes qui elle
même avait accès aux preuves lorsque moi
même je n'en étais pas autorisé puisque
pour rappeler simplement mon rôle au
sein de la chaîne abc private bank
j'étais lorsque je les quitter en charge
des techniques à l'analyse des analyses
techniques pour le département des
projets stratégiques donc des projets
qui avait pour objectif de permettre à
sept banques de s'adapter d'évoluer et
de s'adapter à quoi à des
réglementations à des tentatives de
réguler et aussi de permettre de
contrôler et donc ses activités
bancaires et ceux que j'avais donc
expérimenter ce dont j'avais été témoin
pendant des années c'était que la banque
au lieu de faire évoluer son système
vers des systèmes plus performant plus
rigoureux et qui permettait un meilleur
contrôle des opérations bancaires qui se
déroulait en son sein et bien cherché à
pouvoir se soustraire au mieux à ses
responsabilités et on pourra on aura
locale
non je pense lors de cette audition de
prendre des cas concrets qui aujourd'hui
sont bas de par le temps aussi passé à
notre disposition
quel a été votre motivation fondamentale
vous évoquez nos intérêts fondamentaux
ce qu'on peut partager mais est ce que
vous pourriez précise et détaillée ce
que vous entendez exactement par là et
qu est-ce qui a fait qu'un jour on
d'abord préalablement quelles étaient
vos fonctions exactes au sein de la
banque
en gros quel était votre déroulement de
carrière dans cet établissement bancaire
mais qu'est ce qui fait qu'un jour vous
ayez décidé de d'avoir l'attitude que
vous avez aujourd'hui donc que je veux
saluer à titre personnel mais voilà quel
a été l'élément de bascule à un moment
donné dans votre réflexion et qui dondon
pour ne citer que mon père qui a
travaillé dans la banque privée
je suis né moi même à monaco et la
culture et la connaissance que j'avais
donc de l'activité la banque privée à
l'époque était plutôt associé à quoi la
préservation des biens des propriétés
des personnes de personnes qui étaient
dans des situations assez particulière
qui était souvent entre plusieurs pays
pour des raisons de professionnels qui
étaient dans la nécessité de quitter
leur pays pour des raisons par exemple
de guerre civile et qui donc se
retrouver ou qui a en tout cas mettez
leur bien en sécurité dans des endroits
comme monaco et ça c'est l'expérience
que j'ai eue petit enfant et puis
grandissant quand je rejoins la chaise
baissé en l'an 2000
c'est avec une mission qui est de
constituer un service de recherche et
développement local pour la chaîne abc
monaco et dans ce cadre là il s'agit
donc de le doter de nouveaux outils
informatiques qui vont permettre un
meilleur contrôle des opérations
bancaires
donc ce que je vois moi être dans la
continuité de cette logique bancaire
privée la banque privée qui est de
protéger les biens de clients et en même
temps d'assurer aussi de participer à
quoi la traçabilité aussi bien de 2 c de
ses biens et de leur provenance
selon cela dit le problème
à surgir à lorsque au lieu de cela je me
retrouverais dans une situation où la
volonté sera de faire évoluer vers des
systèmes qui seront qui se révèle moins
performants regard de problématiques de
de sécurité de deux de rigueur et on me
fera donc partager et participer à des
projets qui au lieu donc de permettre un
meilleur contrôle et une meilleure
protection des intérêts même du client
et des du respect des engagements de la
banque iront dans des directions
diamétralement opposées qui permettront
il ya des cas assez emblématique par
exemple de détecter si des gestionnaires
à un moment donné présentant un risque
réputationnel pour la banque ne peuvent
pas être détectées comme tel est invité
à quitter la banque avant même que la
réputation de cette dite banques soient
mises à mal donc vous voyez on rentrait
dans des outils de l'analyse de
connaissances et de suivi des opérations
bancaires qui avaient pour objectif en
fin de compte de dédouaner la banque de
lui éviter d'être exposées
plutôt que d'aider à contrôler et à agir
comme aussi acteur responsable de la de
la place financière pour un rôle qui est
quand même centrale
sur bien des points et je parle de la
rolls du rôle de la banque privée qui
est un peu le comment dire le gras de la
finance là où ou les biens ou majorité
par exemple de la dette souveraine va se
retrouver
est ce qu'il va dire venir monsieur phal
ceni mais quel est l'élément déclencheur
dans votre comportement abandonné
qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous avez
décidé un jour de d'exploiter ces
fichiers donc sur monaco en 2000 et
qu'on rentre je pars en on met en place
un projet qui permet déjà de révélé des
malversations d'un gestionnaire au
détriment des clients sur monaco c'est
le cas steven trotte par la suite
donc ça va me permettre de participer
participez à des projets d'envergure
européenne
ça veut dire au niveau de la direction
sur genève et on me fait participer un
projet qui s'appelle e dms pour gestion
électronique des documents donc un
projet ainsi
m qui est censé garder les documents une
version numérique des documents qui sont
utilisés tous les jours dans la banque
sauf que on me demande et on nous
demande donc avec les personnes qui sont
en charge de ce projet de faire de
substituer un projet à un système qui
est fiable qui est efficace qui permet
d'éviter justement qu'on le modifie
qu'on modifie les informations qu'il
contient
en demande d'avancer d'évoluer vers un
système qui va lui permettre permettre
qu'on puisse modifier les documents
qu'il contient même puisque non plus
enregistrée sur des supports inaltérable
comme des disques optiques ce qui était
le cas pour le précédent système mais
vers des supports qui sont eux tout à
fait modifiable effaçable et ça c'est la
première occasion de la prise de
conscience qu' on est vraiment on rentre
vraiment dans une autre ère où on
pouvait effacer et où on avait la
possibilité donc de d'agir sur quoi sur
les traces de ce que représente et de ce
qui est attesté du patrimoine d'un
client c'est ce que vous entendez par
malversations exactement c'est à dire
qu'à ce moment où je me réalise que au
lieu de fiabiliser un système qui
permettra d'assurer encore plus
professionnellement les devoirs de la
banque vis-à-vis de ses clients évident
à vis des états par la suite ça aussi
que je vais voir eh bien je me rends
compte que déjà là il ya un problème il
ya eu un décalage entre l'action et
l'intention affichée est une des
premières actions sera interne
c'est-à-dire quand on est avant d'être
lanceur d' alerte
il s'agit de se comporter en tant que
témoin et j'ai essayé de l'intérieur
devrait malgré tout pour rétablir la
barre pour redresser la barre et il va
en résulter quoi dans le cas de ce
projet déjà on va obtenir qu avec la
participation des consultants extérieurs
ibm de la compagnie ibm donc et partager
l'effort de ce projet on puisse réaliser
un dossier
un rapport de fin de projet qui a testé
des manquements et des risques
sécuritaires auxquels exposé donc le
remplacement d'un ancien système par ce
nouveau et c'est ainsi que
je vais continuer donc ma progression au
sein de la banque au début donc content
comme simple analyse technique pour un
projet donné et pour finir avec une
vision plus transversale plus gaube la
plus globale de l'ensemble des systèmes
lorsque ultime mans on m'attribue donc
ce rôle de head of technical analystes
et pour donner un peu donc la continuité
pour restituer la continuité de ma
démarche interne et externe la dernière
une des dernières actions que j'ai eu à
mener au sein de la banque pour essayer
aussi de la ramener dans des voies plus
saines et bien sera était d'organiser un
colloque sur la sécurisation des
systèmes de passage d'ordre et ça ce fut
l'occasion de réunir et de sensibiliser
en tout cas d'exprimer les
problématiques à des intervenants de la
banque qui se trouvait aussi bien en
chine tornade et avec donc le soutien
aussi donc d'autres architectes
logiciels en l'occurrence les personnes
qui étaient en irlande mais pour dire
que jusqu'à la fin
ayant malgré tout à un moment donné
réalisé que je ne pourrais rien faire de
probant depuis l'intérieur même de la
banque et qui là qu'il fallait et et
qu'il fallut donc ce se référer à
d'autres autorités
donc même malgré cela même agressé deux
voix d' alerte et bien dans la banque
j'ai continué jusqu'à la fin a essayé
aussi donc d'alerter les personnes qui
étaient en charge qu'avait la
responsabilité de faire en sorte que le
système soit fiable et permettent de
lutter et non pas de laisser faire tout
toutes sortes d'agissements on verra
l'histoire nous le montre on verra que
et c'est intéressant de le rappeler on a
été témoins ces derniers mois de c2c
manque des conséquences de ces
manquements au niveau de la régulation
même de l'outil informatique et je me
réfère à quoi à des systèmes à des
problématiques comme les frères el maleh
vous avez peut-être à l'esprit ces
histoires justement de blanchiment
d'argent de la drogue
qui ont mis en cause cette banque aussi
mais là encore quand comme quand au
début donc de mon intervention je vous
expliquer l'attitude de la banque qui
consiste à éviter à contourner ses
responsabilités et là encore café la
banque
elle leur a fermé le département dans
lequel officiers donc les personnes
incriminées
elle aura demandé aux clients de
clôturer leurs comptes au lieu de quoi
au lieu de chercher à savoir si dans ses
clients certains clients étaient
indésirables était répréhensible
et si dans les employés certains étaient
complices
donc là encore on verra que au lieu
d'aider à la lutte à l'efficacité
financière à la probité et à la légalité
de ces opérations financières
la banque va rentrer dans une démarche
d'évitement et quand personnellement
donc moi successivement je suis témoin
du fait que d'un système robuste on
cherchera à passer à un système
permissible et bien à chaque fois ce
sera une occasion pour m'inciter à
prendre des risques puisque n'ayant pas
un soutien institutionnel sur en tant
que lanceur d' alerte
je vais prendre des risques pour amener
pour constituer déjà l'épreuve pour une
justice et a mené une justice à
s'intéresser à ce qui se passait dans
cette banque
donc première étape je commence
essayez donc de solliciter
l'intervention des autorités françaises
suisses pardon cela ne se faisant pas la
prochaine qui rentrera en lice sera
celle française et ça sera par
simplement par un téléphone un appel à
la brigade de lutte conte de la police
judiciaire contre la haute délinquance
financière qui elle va en fait me mettre
dans les mains de l'administration
fiscale
mais ma première démarche et c'est
l'occasion aussi de le répéter fut
orienté vers la justice et la justice
suisse puis d'autres justice dont celle
française évidemment de suite après
celle suisse
après il y aurait différents éléments
qui seront intéressés de partager le
fait que ne serait ce que pour avoir
donc aujourd'hui dans les mains de la
justice française et d'autres justice
ces éléments de preuve il a fallu avoir
le soutien de d'organismes de
renseignement de services de
renseignements qui ont permis d'amener
leur soutien logistique à ce qu'on
sécurise ses informations pour qu'on
puisse il transmettre parce qu'il ne
faut pas oublier et là je reviens encore
là dessus que mon rôle ne donnait pas
accès aux informations sensibles que ces
informations sensibles ont été sécurisés
et délivrés dans les mains de la justice
exclusivement pas dans des médias ou des
systèmes de diffusion de l'information
comme wikileak donc ont été délivrés
dans les mains de la justice
grâce à une infrastructure grâce à un
support logistique qui a été fourni donc
par certains acteurs des services
secrets de renseignement et là aussi il
faut comprendre que dans tout ce qui est
du domaine de la transparence dans tout
ce qui est du domaine de la lutte contre
l'opacité
il n'y a pas d'alternative au
renseignement il n'y a pas d'alternative
au fait de connaître quelle est la
nature de la menace à laquelle nous
sommes exposés donc peut-être
effectivement on arrive à une limite en
termes diplomatiques mais il faut
comprendre que normalement entre alliés
con ce que l'on observe mutuellement ça
peut être pour les meilleures raisons du
monde donc il faut acter je pense qu'il
faut aussi prendre l'occasion de mon
expérience et mon retour d'expérience
pour acter que les enseignants sont
utiles et que ce sont surtout des
personnes mal intentionnées qui auront
intérêt à ce que nous on n'est pas de
transparence et pour peu que bien sûr ça
ne soit pas il s'agisse pas comme je
vous le dis comme je lé fais moi je
ferais bien la différence entre l'état
lâche public et l'accès et la
transparence aux informations utiles
pour quoi pour la préservation
de notre intérêt général vous dites
monsieur que vous n'aviez pas accès
forcément vous directement
personnellement à certaines informations
en particulier certains ordinateurs
enfin certaines informations contenues
informatiquement et les services secrets
certes mais pour autant il faut bien
contre il y ait des personnes qui
fournissent ces renseignements alors ma
question est assez simple parce que vous
avez actuellement des contacts
personnels avec des personnes qui
peuvent vous fournir des informations
mais qui n'ont pas encore accepté
officiellement de prendre comme on
dirige la cape du lanceur d alerte
il ya évidemment j'ai évidemment
évidemment en tête différentes personnes
qui seraient à même d'amener un
témoignage est d'amener des
éclaircissements sur bien des points qui
méritent de l'être d'éclaircies la
problématique n'est pas tant leur
existence est vraiment comment est
vraiment comment leur permettre et
permettre à ce que ben d'autres aussi
que je ne connaîtrais pas puissent le
faire mais l'évènement vous allez les
contacter éric ces gens là page et que
je continue effectivement avoir des
contacts sur sur comment évolue le
système et puis même par intermédiaire
c'est-à-dire en ayant aussi travaillé
dans avec d'autres d'autres justice dans
d'autres structures
d'autres pays seront équipés de deux
mécanismes de renseignement de systèmes
de renseignement qui vous permettront de
garder malgré tout une vision assez à
jour de ce qui se passe donc de l'autre
côté du mur de l'autre côté de satin
france et de certaines frontières là je
parlais du mur du secret bancaire mais
mais bref
oui j'ai quand même effectivement encore
certain nombre d'informations qui me
reviennent oui monsieur fait si j'ai pas
très bien compris les raisons qui vous
ont conduit à avoir des soupçons clair
sur les données des fameux fichier hsbc
est ce que vous pourriez y revenir s'il
vous plaît
parce que vous avez suggéré n'avoir pas
accès ne va pas eu accès aux données
mais que celle ci avait été extraite
grâce aux services de renseignement
c'est ce que voulait dire à l'instant et
se côtoyer clarifier ce point s'il vous
plaît bien sûr en fait ce que j'ai
j'ai essayé de le partager avec vous
c'est simplement que au niveau de
l'accès à ces informations ces éléments
preuve j'ai eu l'aide d'autres personnes
au sein de la banque
par contre pour assurer assuré le fait
que personne n'ait en sa possession ces
éléments de preuve personne d'autre que
des justices déjà eh bien il a fallu
recourir un certain nombre d' expertise
en terme de sécurisation et de transport
de ces informations
puisque bon il faut bien il faut bien
comprendre que il ya une différence
entre l'obtention et la mise à
disposition et c'est dans la mise à
disposition qu'il a fallu qu'on m'aide
je parle là en l'occurrence des services
de renseignement
par contre pour ce qui est de
l'obtention pas à ma connaissance ils
n'ont pas intérêt sont pas intervenus à
ce niveau là ma connaissance puisque ils
sont intervenus dans cette mise à
disposition
aussi suite à ma demande c'est à dire
que quand moi je me trouve face à une
situation inextricable où je ne vois
vraiment pas comment je vais réussir
premièrement à sécuriser ces
informations et à les faire parvenir
dans les mains souhaité et bien je
j'alerte les personnes les compétences
d'état qui me semble à même de m'aider
dans ma démarche et ça passera donc par
la sollicitation d'un certain nombre de
services de renseignement ce qui fait
que encore aujourd'hui malgré la la
présentation malgré le nom sur
lesquelles ces personnes se sont
présentées à moi et on aider
concrètement factuellement je n'aurais
jamais en tout cas je ne peux je n'ai
pas aujourd'hui l'assurance de leur
réelle identité déclarée ce que je sais
c'est que leur réaction a été positive
et a permis dans les cadres qu'on
s'était donné d'aboutir à ce que la
justice aujourd'hui c'est probable
vous voulez vous voulez dire que les
documents enfin les pièces que vous avez
obtenu vous les avez obtenu anonymement
c'est à dire que vous ne mettez pas un
nom sur la personne qui vous a fait vous
a transmis une information ou un non pas
du tout dans les informations
moi j'ai eu j'ai eu deux rôles
premièrement donc un rôle pour assurer
l'acheminement dans lé manager six de
ces informations
et deuxièmement j'ai eu le rôle
d'assurer que ces informations soient
consistante
c'est à dire elles m'ont été donnés par
des personnes que je connaissais et les
ayant obtenu j'ai dû m'assurer de leur
intégrité et cela fait je les ai mis
après ggg je dirige et profiter de
l'assistance a mené par justement
services de renseignements pour pouvoir
les mettre à disposition
mais avant de passer la parole à notre
collègue marie noëlle lienemann
est-ce que vous avez pris le temps
d'analyser ces fichiers ou même avant de
vous en saisir et qu'est ce que vous
avez pu observer à l'occasion de cette
analyse que vous avez éventuellement
fait elles ont certainement été partiel
étant donné l'ampleur des données qui
sont assez assez conséquente qu'est ce
qui a retenu votre attention à l'examen
de ces données des noms des montant
d'encours par exemple en aucun cas on
n'est qu'un cas je me suis intéressé si
on peut dire aux particularités aux
instances d'opérations bancaires encore
moins ou non par contre quand vous
parlez de partialité non ceux qui on
s'est fait fort de récupérer c'est
l'intégralité donc l'intégralité à la
fois de quoi de certains systèmes qui
montrait quoi qu'il montre est justement
la permissivité de la banque et ses
agissements et dans ce cadre donc c'est
simplement parce que eh bien pour que ce
système fonctionne il devait contenir
des listes de clients qu'on pouvait
retrouver des listes de clients mais mon
principal intérêt à l'origine était de
restituer les éléments explicatifs de
comment fonctionne la banque et de façon
la plus
factuel la plus comment dire
inattaquable possible en restituant en
l'état dans lesquels se trouvaient ces
informations au sein même de la banque
ça veut dire sans constituer par exemple
des listes tels que ce fut fait par des
administrations qui avaient des mandats
et qui ont eu des mandats précis et est
limité limité à des listes déjà donc
moins en aucun cas je me suis intéressé
à dellys mais je me suis intéressé à
l'intégrité de systèmes et d les
éléments qui représentait le
fonctionnement de ces systèmes et à la
mise à disposition donc de ces éléments
je vais donner la parole à madame à
notre collègue qui veulent ont posé une
question et monsieur deux questions la
première c'est que vous indiquez que
vous êtes donc bénéficié du soutien de
services de services de renseignement
pour faire passer si je puis dire les
informations à un stade opérationnel
pour la justice je voudrais vous
demander on avait entendu à l'époque
ministre des finances nous indiquait
qu'il avait une liste de noms mais que
cette liste ne pouvaient pas être
utilisées parce qu'elle avait été entre
guillemets volée et n'avait pas été
légalement transmises à la justice
est-ce que vous avez connaissance des
mécanismes transmission est ce que de
votre point de vue il avait été
illégalement transmis
c'est le premier point est la deuxième
chose puisque il ya des services de
renseignement donc quelle est la nature
de ses services de renseignement en
termes de d'efficacité juridique de ce
passage la deuxième chose c'est que vous
ai parlé des projets stratégiques
vous dites que dans l'organisation de la
banque il y avait des systèmes de
compétence de la banque qui était mis au
service de projets stratégiques
or nous nous réfléchissons à la manière
dont les états la puissance publique
peut organiser sa riposte devant
l'évasion fiscale qui est un mécanisme
qui s'adapte très vite comme un virus
mutant quoi et donc est ce que de votre
point de vue il y aurait pas nécessité
d'une sorte de
de similitudes d'organisation c'est à
dire d'avoir des task force d qui
travaillent sur des projets stratégiques
de lutte contre l'évasion fiscale et
pouvez vous nous dire ce qu'il en est de
ses projets stratégiques qui se
réunissaient dans les banques
quelles compétences étaient mises en
oeuvre pour voir si éventuellement par
symétrie serait pas utile de croiser les
compétences au sein de l'état bien
volontiers répondre à votre question
donc pour la première lorsqu'il s'agit
justement de delà des procédures
fiscales et judiciaires
toutes les informations mais quand j'ai
parlé du rôle de certains services de
renseignement donc il a permis quoi il a
permis le fait un fait unique dans
l'histoire que des informations soient
transmises à la justice française par la
justice suisse c'est à dire toutes les
informations dont on a discuté et dont
on a entendu parler pendant des années
ont été mises à disposition par à la
suite d'une demande d'entraidé
judiciaire suisse
donc c'est de parler demande de saisie
de scellés et les résultats donc de ces
saisies donc les scellés de cette
commission rogatoire internationale
suisse a permis à la france et à la
justice française de récupérer ces
informations ce qui veut dire qu'il n'y
aura jamais eu plus directs et plus
naturels transmission de données que
dans ce cadre là que dans le cas dans ce
cas unique donc de ce qu'on appellera
sûrement la faire hsbc
quand un ministre prétend parle de
données volées il ne peut s'agir ne peut
s'agir que d'une manipulation qu'une
entrave
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui encore
aucun jugement n'a été prononcé sur quoi
que ce soit dans cette affaire donc
encore moins de vols de données
donc quand un représentant l'autorité
quand un élu quand quelqu'un qui devrait
soutenir les lois prétend cela eh bien
c'est du domaine de l' entrave
c'est du domaine de la manipulation et
contre nos intérêts propres
ça c'est mon point de vue de citoyen
deux témoins de ce que j'ai vécu parce
que il y aura d'autres épisodes qu'ils
s'affaireront à 7,7 cet événement-là de
déclarations comme quoi des données ont
été volées
et ses autres interventions auront été
par exemple le fait de brandir une liste
site aurait pu être très bien fait un an
plus tard laissant le temps aux
institutions judiciaires de progresser
d'enquêté tranquillement sans qu'on
alerte les personnes qui risquaient une
enquête et bon après on pourrait
continuer dans le sens mais il ya une
autre question là pour les hautes
fonctions il aura eu de nombreuses il
n'aura eu au plus haut niveau
il ya eu des demandes de destruction de
scellés en les retournant à la suisse il
aura été demandée d'accord que non
seulement une copie des scellés soient
communiqués à la suisse mais carrément
que l'on retourne les scellés à la
suisse ce qui rentre à entraîner quoi
judiciairement une destruction de
preuves de preuves pour donc quoi pour
des preuves qui aujourd'hui
historiquement soit un des premiers cas
dans dans notre histoire donc de la
lutte contre l'opacité financière et et
l'évasion fiscales sont uniques
donc moi je conclurai là pour cette
première question sur justement
lorsqu'on a parlé et mystifier donc le
public et bien d'autres jusqu'à
justement des magistrats sur la notion
de données volées et puis je reviendrai
donc sur la deuxième question qui est
justement comment faire face à cette
menace
alors chaque fois qu'on a une menace on
pense en terme de défense donc la
défense nationale juste quelques jours
après donc 14 juillet il est important
de de faire le rapprochement entre les
différents types de menaces auxquelles
nous sommes exposés dans le cadre de la
menace donc de l'opacité financière de
la dérégulation de l'absence de contrôle
de ses opérations puisque comme je vous
le disais en début de séance
eh bien nous avons des personnes qui au
lieu de prendre des responsabilités et
partir et participer à la lutte contre
justement là la délinquance financière
il faut ils prendront soin
de d'éviter toute exposition à ces
risques
simplement eh bien on verra que donc on
manque on manque d'autorité qui se
substitueront et qui rempliront ce rôle
qui se substitueront à ces acteurs
financiers et qui rempliront ce rôle
donc dans la banque on aura des systèmes
d'adaptation on peut essayer c'est un
axe extrêmement important effectivement
de reproduire des systèmes qui vont
offrir des vaccins qui s'adapteront fur
à mesure que ce virus se muera et donc
pour ce faire et bien reprendre me la
même dynamique d'adaptation de nos
défense tout comme il y à des mécanismes
dès qu'elle met des mécanismes
d'adaptation de ce qu'on va dire ces
virus si vous comprenez on comprendra
bien de quoi je parle alors
effectivement ça passera par quoi par
constituer des équipes l'équivalent
sûrement d'un département projets
stratégiques
quelque chose qui se rapprochera de ce
que l'on aura en espagne sous le nom
rassembler sous le nom de pro qe2
parquet anti corruption où on aura un
ensemble de compétences dire qu à
l'identique que dans le département
stratégique on avait un ensemble de
compétences réunies et bien à nous aussi
de constituer ce genre de d'entités pour
ben justement d'un côté pouvoir
récupérer les informations sur les
menaces auxquelles on nous sommes
exposés de l'autre analyse et ses
menaces
donc vous voyez bien il ya la
connaissance métier ce sera dans la
banque
un département qui est dédié à la
connaissance du métier et des
opportunités proposées à la banque et la
propre et la plupart du temps une
opportunité c'est quoi c'est une
évolution réglementaire
donc ce que lorsque nous ici nous
cherchons à entraver un comportement qui
nous est pénalisant et bien la banque
elle va prendre cela comme une
opportunité nous pour need et pour
prendre un service d'évitement pour
proposer un service d'évitement et pour
proposer ses services
donc le projet stratégique va faire quoi
et bien va étudier quelles sont les
modification en son sein qu'il doit être
opéré et va donc mener à son terme ces
modifications et donc nous on pourrait
effectivement connaissent en prenant
connaissance de comment la banque va
s'organiser pour faire face à une
réglementation et bien évaluer un plan
d'action qui aura pour but de
contrecarrer 7,7 cette offre
cette offre de services nouveaux à venir
et qui par les les structures en
présence vient souvent avant même la
date de mise en application de ces
réglementations
oui avec la permission de mon collègue
jacques chiron qui est une question à
poser
vous voulez dire que les fichiers ont
été transmis dans le cadre d'une
commission rogatoire
certes mais par qui at elle été formulée
d'abord et d'après ce qu'on sait c'est
la justice suisse qui a fait cette
demande donc dans comment ça s'est passé
en détail donc moi une fois sur france
je me fais fort donc de récupérer les
informations une fois surprendre je ne
suis pas sortie de suisse avec des
informations avec les preuves que je
comptais donner à la justice française
mais je les ai récupérées sur france ses
preuves et les ayants chez moi lorsque
la commission rogatoire s'exécute et
biens sont saisis à mon domicile
ces informations que j'avais donc
récupérer et validé à nouveau donc c'est
ces scellés sont effectuées par la
gendarmerie nationale sont transmises
donc directement au parquet par les
services secrets ou non directement par
l'action de la série par l'exécution de
la commission rogatoire internationale
demandée par la suisse donc c'est dense
où la demande
c'est sous sous sous la tutelle de la
suisse que ces informations sont
récupérées transmises à la justice
française et à comment dire finie
his atterrissent dans les mains de la
justice française et c'est là où moi je
vais alerté le procureur monsieur eric
de montgolfier sur l'intérêt pour la
préservation de de nos deux de nos
intérêts fondamentaux qu'il fallait
qu'il qui s'intéressent à ces
informations et non pas qu'il ait
retransmettent sans rien faire à la
suisse comme celle ci le demander et
donc c'est sensé aussi et
essentiellement par son action ben que
ses preuves la finirons dans les mains
de la justice française note collecte
chiron va vous poser une question le
système d'évitement de la part d'abord
c'était sur les a considérées comme
criminelles à l'échelon international
c'est à dire que ils ont voulu cacher
parce que j'ai compris un certain nombre
de comptes relevant d'actes criminels
donc ça signifie pour éviter déclaré je
vais si vous voulez c'est
malheureusement c'est plus c'est plus
étendue la problématique est les plus
étendus que consciente aux coups simples
cas de cette banque qui est déjà
emblématique de par sa taille
si vous permettez je vais reformuler
pour être bien sûr de mettre bien
exprimer vous avez un système financier
qui est un peu constitué comme un oeuf
vous avez une coquille et vous avez deux
dans une matière molle dans laquelle on
pourrait se déplacer une fois passée la
coquille est une coquille est assez
faible d'accord donc la coquille c'est
là où se concentre la responsabilité au
regard par exemple des institutions
judiciaires suisses et que requis qui
constituent cette coquille ce sont les
gestionnaires de fortune au niveau de la
banque ce qui veut dire que imaginez
vous vous avez donc une entité le
système financier qui repose pour
lesquels responsabilité de ce qui s'y
déroule repose sur la tête de quelques
individus
officiellement donc ça veut dire que la
banque elle va se permettre d'offrir
tous les services que vont demander ces
gestionnaires pour des raisons
commerciales et par contre si le
gestionnaire fait pas ce qu'il ce qu'il
devrait ce sera lui qui sera responsable
au niveau de la loi
or comment lui restituer cette
responsabilité si on n'est pas à même de
déceler son activité et c'est toute la
problématique de la banque
dire que si il n'y a pas un contrôle de
cette marque parties molles qui
représente l'essentiel de la finance eh
bien on ne pourra jamais ou très
difficilement restituer leurs
responsabilités à la coquille haut
niveau la copie au niveau des
intermédiaires au niveau des
gestionnaires et c'est simplement et
c'est toute la subtilité de la démarche
c'est que en rendant de plus en plus
fines
cette coquille en l'éloignant de plus en
plus de ce qu'est la banque donc de
l'oeuf de la matière molle de l'oeuf et
bien la banque participe aide à ce que
ben nous nous soyons démunis face à des
comportements délictueux et je vous ai
cité des exemples des frères elle
n'allait en france les exemples j'aurais
pu vous prendre aussi l'exemple par
exemple du d'un chef de la mafia
chinoise en espagne gao ping qui
utilisaient quoi la même banque
cette même banque hsbc genève et dans
les deux cas pour du blanchiment et dans
les deux cas dans des cadres qui
mettront qui se poseront en termes
judiciaires qui simplement les
intermédiaires simplement les
intermédiaires et la banque
elle réussira toujours à se maintenir
hors de toute poursuite jusqu'ici parce
que les réglementations sont fait tel
pays telle qu'elle est c'est bien ça la
difficulté c'est que ce ne sont pas avec
des réglementations qu'on va pouvoir
interférer avec ces mécanismes avec ces
comportements se seront bien avec des
aptitudes avec des actions dynamiques
ce sera bien a par exemple en se
rapprochant des intermédiaires
financiers
quand l'amérique demande à la suisse
l' échange automatique d des noms des
clients
la suisse bon gré mal gré va accepter
varrault chine et va présenter comme bon
si c'était très grave mais va accepter
parce que le temps que ça passait en
vigueur elle aura déjà trouvé un
mécanisme d'évitement
par contre quand on lui demande à la
suisse de communiquer ces intermédiaires
ses avocats toute personne qui aura un
rôle déterminant dans ses activités
financières et bien là il y aura une
levée de boucliers généralisée alors là
on en arrivera à la limite de la
coopération et c'est tout le point c'est
que c'est tout est dans la subtilité on
n'est pas dans du gros oeuvre
on est vraiment dans de l'orfèvrerie et
dans ses plats et dans ce travail là
dans ce domaine là il ya des places qui
concentre ses compétences et qui nous
oblige nous nous oblige nous donc à
acquérir ces mêmes compétences pour
pouvoir rivaliser et donc à ré
reconstituer un environnement qui
permettra à ses compétences de se
développer et d'être au même niveau que
celles est bien de nos opposants très
bien oui personnellement je voudrais
poser une autre question d'en haut début
lorsqu'on évoque un nombre de comptes
révélé par vos informations
on évoqua un nombre x par la suite
interrogeant les différentes personnes
qui ont pu accéder à ses comptes qui ont
pu les vérifier qui on peut les
contrôler on nous indique que certains
sont des doublons que certains font des
comptes déclaré epsilon quelques-uns et
que certains ont des et annule son
décompte soldés et ont fini par aboutir
à x / 4 / 5 pour vous c'est crédible
alors déjà je me remettrai jamais en
cause le travail de l'administration
parce que j'ai vu avec quel moyen il
avait oeuvré et
vrai labrie responsabilité réside dans
le fait de ne pas lui avoir donné
jusqu'ici des moyens maintenant pour
prendre pour revenir aux déchets aux
chiffres il faut voir que nous sommes
dans une situation complexe et comme on
le comprend bien
si on n'a pas une connaissance perfect
pas perf est parfait pendant deux de ses
mécanismes on ne pourra pas ayant
l'épreuve devant les yeux on ne pourra
pas les exploiter
ça veut dire que si je viens et c'est ce
que j'ai vécu d'ailleurs quand je me
suis retrouvé face à une quantité
astronomique de d'informations à
partager avec par exemple
l'administration fiscale ces messieurs
étaient bien démuni face à ça ils ne
pouvaient pas l'exploiter on a travaillé
pendant des mois pour exploiter une
partie une simple une partie la plus
intéressante par rapport à leurs mandats
exclusifs sur quelques mois on a pu
exploiter ces quelques informations mais
tout le reste qui était juste adossé à
ce qu'on avait exploité
faute de pouvoir expliquer de quoi il
sent il s'en retourne et ils n'ont pas
pu les exploiter et des éléments aussi
importants que les intermédiaires
financiers dont on me parle et ne
sachant pas qui les équipes étaient
représentées sous tel format dans ces
informations ils n'étaient pas même pour
les exploiter
donc quand on parle de liste il faut
comprendre qu'on parle d'extraction ça
veut dire c'est comme une prise de sang
à un organisme
on aura une vue ciblé choisi d'un
organisme ce sera par exemple sans sa
glycémie
donc quand on va voir par exemple qu'on
va faire une prise de sang qui
correspond à une liste une liste de da
de compte on aura quoi comme doublons
alors reprenant les chiffres on aura
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
comptes comptes bancaires sachant qu'une
personne pouvant détenir plusieurs
comptes
donc on peut très bien avoir une liste
où on aura pour sur plusieurs lignes
le même nom mais avec un compte
différent donc ça ça constituera un
double en terme de personne mais pas un
doublon en termes d'information on aura
plusieurs comptes pour une même personne
ensuite quand il s'agit d'établir par
exemple un patrimoine pour une personne
si on connaît pas les les biens les les
produits financiers qui sont disponibles
pour les clients
eh bien on va se retrouver dans des
situations qui sont assez inattendu pour
pour les personnes justement qui ne les
connaissent pas je vais vous prendre
l'exemple des dépôt fiduciaire le dépôt
de fiduciaire ce correspond consiste à
déléguer la propriété d'un bien
un peu comme pour les trusts sauf que là
c'est un dépôt vous avez un million vous
donnez vous déléguez vous transmettez 7
la propriété de ce million par an
pendant 6 mois
donc pendant six mois ce bien simple
comme pour de certaines formes
d'assurances-vie
ben ce bien va être à la propriété de la
banque donc si vous on regarde l'état de
vos biens
vous avez zéro vous avez moins 1000 - un
million - 10 millions donc si vous il
vous reste par exemple donc dans sur une
si vous lisez une liste dans lequel
apparaîtra d'un côté en positif 5
millions et de l'autre moins un million
votre premier réflexe à sera de
soustraire et d'obtenir 4 millions sauf
que ceux - 1 millions correspond à la
trace dans le système du fait que vous
détenez 5 millions et non pas trois mais
comment comment un client de la banque
simplement excusez moi pour arriver à la
conclusion de ce que je comptais
partager avec vous rien que là le
patrimoine d'un client n'est pas quelque
chose d'intuitif n'est pas quelque chose
qui pourra faute de connaître vraiment
la banque qui pourraient être établies
par une simple disposition disponibilité
d'informations
donc si vous détenez des informations
bancaires si vous n'êtes pas à même de
bien les interpréter
vous allez arriver à des décalages très
conséquent comment un client d'une
banque
entrant dans ce type de mécanisme la
peut-il se préserver conte
entre l'appréhension de ses propres
fonds je connais dans le culte complet
la déléguée la propriété à un
intervenant une personne interposée
comment peut-il se prémunir de récupérer
cet argent et d'échapper à une propre
fraude de la bande à 100 détriment vous
revenez sur sur un apprentissage que
j'ai eu tout jeune encore une fois où
mon père quand les premiers mots qui m'a
transmis les premières
mais oui les éléments de compréhension
de la banque qui m'a transmis furent la
banque la négation de la confiance il
faut viser et supervisé c'est un
principe il ya des principes comme ça
comme le principe des quatre yeux où on
devrait assurer que chaque opération
soit visée superviser donc pour éviter
justement que quelqu'un de mal
intentionné puisse détourner des biens
et à une époque donc ou l'époque où il
me transmettait ses connaissances on
était dans de l'époque où les éléments
étaient sur des cahiers sur des
registres où on ne pouvait pas effacer
on ne pouvait pas faire disparaître
comme l'informatique la permis depuis et
c'est toute la difficulté c'est à dire
que quand on parle de secret on va on va
revenir à des à ddd événement qu'on a
qu'on a connue sous le terme par exemple
des fonds en déshérence et si on voit
c'est pas simplement spécifique à la
suisse aux endroits où on aura un secret
baquet bancaire très très exigeant mais
déjà en france ça existe déjà en france
quand vous allez estimé les biens en
déshérence en france eh ben vous pourrez
par ce sera même plus un facteur
multiplicatif mais sera plutôt
exponentielle vous pouvez imaginer ce
qui peut se produire
derrière un mur aussi au plus le mur
sera sera solide ailleurs vous pourrez
imaginer donc qu'est ce qui pourra se
passer derrière mur comme le mieux le
secret bancaire suisse
merci nous allons revenir au question de
notre reporter merci monsieur le
président oui afin de bien comprendre
autre cheminement monsieur fassiez vous
avez dit tout à l'heure que vous avez
quitté le territoire suisse si j'ai bien
compris sans être en possession des
documents des fichiers en question
et dans ce cas là la question se pose de
savoir qui vous a aidé au transfert de
ces données est ce que ça est ce que les
services secrets ont eu un rôle concret
dans cette opération la voilà ça c'est
la première question que je voulais vous
poser ensuite deuxième question dans
quelles conditions la justice suisse
vous at-elle identifié comme étant
possesseur de ces fichiers et troisième
question pour cette série là
quelles ont été vos interlocuteurs au
ministère des finances en france un
témoin a fait état de divers tractations
dans les services fiscaux ça a été
repris dans la presse à plusieurs
reprises
est ce que vous pourriez donner des
précisions sur leurs objets pour la
dernière partie pour la dernière vos
questions je suis pas très je peux tout
à fait sûr d'avoir bien compris quand
vous parlez de 30 ans de tractations bon
pour revenir donc et prendre dans
l'ordre vos questions mais c'est en fait
c'est le juge de montgolfier qu'on a
auditionné l'an dernier qui faisait état
de ce sont ces propos que nous reprenons
en attendant l'audition et voilà il a
fait état de cette situation
moi je vais vous restituer ce qu'il
s'est passé un aussi bien donc à partir
du moment où j'ai quitté la suisse et
après lorsqu'ils essaient s'agit de
travailler donc avec comprise
l'administration fiscale donc lorsque je
quitte la suisse effectivement je n'ai
pas d'information avec moi aucune
information j'entends france sans rien
et quand je vous ai parlé donc du rôle
de certains services de renseignement il
s'agit sur la mise de la sécurisation la
mise en sécurité de ces informations
pour qu'elles puissent être disponibles
aussi bien depuis la france que depuis
l'espagne ou que le but de tout autre
pays sans que sans courir le risque que
par ma disparition elles disparaissent
aussi donc c'est simplement ça c'est à
dire que et l'essentiel du rôle des
services de renseignements a été donc
d'assurer cela une partie aussi quand
même bien importante aura été dans les
mécanismes qui ont entraîné la suisse
à venir perquisitionné sur france qui
cela aussi est de l'heure et de leur
tribu leur revient c'est aussi grâce à
eux qu'on a pu organiser cette
judiciarisation dans le pays où les
réglementation nous impose et nous évite
de pouvoir vraiment lutter efficacement
mais bon c'est un autre débat c'est un
autre sujet quand donc une fois rentrés
et une fois ces données perquisitionné
donc disponible pour la justice
française
une fois cela fait moi j'ai simplement à
mener donc mais éclaircissements sur la
nature des informations comme je
l'expliquais les informations tel quel
si je voulais donner et si j'ai donné
aux personnes les plus expertes dans la
lutte au niveau français si je vais
donner demain
il serait bien là même d'établir qu'ils
ne peuvent rien en faire ne saurais pas
quoi en faire et qu'il pourrait
retrouver peut-être quelques noms
étaient en fait le le test fut enfin si
quand moi je leur ai transmis ses
données
je n'avais pas de connaissances
particulières sur leur niveau de
compétence sur l'exploitation sur leur
capacité d'exploiter ces données et ce
sont eux qui sont revenus vers moi pour
me dire écoute j'ai bien vu qu'il y
avait des noms par ci par là mais je
suis incapable de pouvoir les utiliser
et c'est à ce moment que j'ai commencé à
travailler avec donc tractactions
correspondant à quoi comment
correspondant justement à un travail à
l'organisation d'un travail à des
réunions les seuls
élément de 30 ans de tractations que je
vois et que j'ai vécu on était
afférentes au fait d'organiser des
séances de travail le travail
explicatifs et gracieusement évidemment
comme à chaque fois donc tout au long de
ces années j'ai amené ma contribution
aussi bien au niveau de la migration
fiscal que que de la justice française
mais la justice gracieusement
volontairement et en ayant comme limite
simplement le temps qu'on m'avait
imparti pour le faire c'est à dire que
dans un ensemble d'obstruction dont nous
avons été victimes puisque c'est nos
intérêts qui est enclin pâtissent à
terme et bien a été aussi organisés le
fait que je ne puisse pas de façon
consistante apporter tout mon aide ne
serait ce que dans l'explication des
mécanismes dans le fait de mettre en
place une défense qui soit à la hauteur
de 2,2 de des menaces mais aujourd'hui
les choses sont sont d'une autre nature
les intentions sont différentes et je
suis plus qu'optimiste je suis certain
qu'on va réussir à redresser la barre je
précisément sur ce point vous avez
incontestablement une expertise très
précieuse d'abord vous êtes ingénieur
système en plus vous connaissez le
système bancaire qui organise le
l'opacité
donc vous avez une expertise j'allais
dire monnayable est ce que l'état
français vous a proposé de vous
rémunérer pour que vous agissiez en
qualité d'experts pour analyser ces
informations que vous nous dites
difficilement analysable par d'autres
peut-être alors ma question est est ce
que l'état français vous a proposé de 2
vous indemniser de vous de cette
expertise voir est-ce que vous n'êtes
non en aucun cas
en aucun cas jamais et puis j'ai offert
gracieusement mon mon aide
depuis le début non dans ce que dans des
temps d oui que dans des domaines limité
jusqu'ici
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
chercher une voix une voix pour
justement que je puisse apporter mon
aide puisque pour que je puisse
continuer cette lutte qui est devenu un
engagement personnel
mais comment prairie visual comment vous
expliquez ça que vous offrez la votre
expertise l'année un certain nombre de
choses et à tous les nouveaux on nous
indiquait il ya un blocage
on ne permet même pas d'aidé d'apporter
mon expérience comment vous expliquez ça
moi lieu aux yeux on ne m'a pas aidé fin
oui désolé le monde
ben je vais vous dire si on prend alors
prenons pas pour pour la partie la plus
emblématique
prenons donc le précédent président la
république qui va prétendre que les
paradis fiscaux sont finis
c'est à son action concrète la seule
dont moi je puisse témoigner dont nous
pouvons tous témoigner parce que
malheureusement je peux pas témoigner
qu'il ait aidé à quoi que ce soit pour
ma part il ya 100 seules actions
concrètes aura été de permettre au
panama de pouvoir continuer à travailler
donc c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
prenons revenons aux faits d'accord le
précédent le gouvernement de le
précédent gouvernement et son
représentant pour être très précis et
concis j avais quand il a eu une action
à mener quand il a mené une action ça a
été pour rendre une place qui est tout à
fait connu pour ses dérives dans la
gestion des patrimoines immobiliers
qu'elles panama et donc la france
qu'elle a eu une action
elle a été au niveau des paradis fiscaux
sous la présidence de monsieur sarkozy a
été néfaste pour nos intérêts personnels
pour tous nos intérêts généraux
donc je réponds aussi à votre question
c'est pas des tours et parce que je peux
pas faire état d'une aide
qui a été apporté dans cette lutte au
regard de ma connaissance des moyens de
lutte dont on aurait besoin et dont on a
besoin
mais je peux vous faire état de ce qui a
été fait et qui va contre nos intérêts
il est exact vous n'avez pas pu
rencontrer monsieur quel visage lorsque
vous avez également volubile fournir des
informations je vous le confirme je n'ai
autant cette lutte dépend dépasse les
partis politiques puisque c'est du
domaine de l'intérêt général et nous
sommes tous dans la même barque
si je puis dire autant ya effectivement
des personnes qui ont eu un rôle clé et
le pire dans la corruption ce n'est pas
de faire quelque chose contre même si
comme je vous disais il ya eu des
actions contre qui ont été menées non le
pire dans la corruption c'est de laisser
rien faire et de ne pas aider à ce que
ce soit fait parce que ce sont des
déterminations et ce sont des actions
concrètes franche kid nécessite un
investissement un engagement qui
permettent de lutter contre une telle
menace
quand vous savez qu'il s'agit de parents
et c'est une estimation à minima de
plusieurs dizaines de milliards
quand on comprenait que l'enjeu est de
cet ordre
eh bien vous comprenez que ça
nécessiterait un pourcentage
c'est un jeu d'investissement est
aujourd'hui l'investissement est né
n'est pas fait même à minima
donc c'est l'intérêt aussi de nos
rencontres c'est l'intérêt de comprendre
que nous avons la possibilité de faire
mais que simplement aujourd'hui et je
suis heureux de voir que dans le
gouvernement que dans l'administration
il ya un changement qui se laisse qui se
laisse sentir qu'ils envoient d'arrivée
et qu'on va peut-être donc grâce à cela
si on le maintien si on mettait à cet
effort et si on le mène à son terme
on va enfin pouvoir se doter d'une
défense qui soit adapté à la menace est
ce que vous pourriez précisé monsieur
fonctionne il est ce que vous entendez
par action contre d'une part et je
pourrai revenir un peu en arrière sur
les types d'opérations des cas concrets
que vous aviez annoncé nous d'étayer
nous soyons très preneur de quelques
exemples très concrets de ce type
d'opération dans cette activité s'il
vous plaît
oui bien donc il y en a de toutes sortes
si on prend des exemples par exemple sur
les régulations les réglementations
l'équivalent on a on a un exemple
aujourd'hui dans la lutte
l'exemple américain corps donc quand je
vous dis qui a été fait contre donc un
des acteurs phares dans la lutte contre
l'opacité financière est en tout cas
l'évasion fiscale a été jusqu'ici
l'amérique les états unis d'amérique
et qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait quand ils
ont cherché donc simplement à mettre la
pression a révélé à expliquer les
mécanismes et à obtenir des informations
quand il ne pouvait pas le faire
directement ils ont mis en place des
réglementations comme le qualified
intermediary le qi qui permettait donc
la taxation des ressortissants
américains sur la base de la de
l'origine des produits qu'ils détenaient
donc si c'était des produits d'origine
américaine est bien une partie des
bénéfices issus des tensions ces
produits devaient être versés et dans ce
cadre-là la banque se comporter en
percepteurs pour l'amérique quand la
france - quand l'europe façon plus
générale a cherché à faire la même chose
et ce qui est ce qui s'est trouvée
appelé par le sd european séverine
directive
qu'est ce qu'il en est ressorti que la
réglementation s'occuper prévoyez de
taxer les personnes physiques et non pas
les personnes morales donc donc la
faille ou plutôt la démarche le projet
stratégique a conquis a pris le biais de
cette évolution réglementaire a été 2
identifier les personnes qui payerait
plus que la mise en place d'une
structure légale derrière laquelle il
aurait pu donc s'abriter qui qui aurait
pu payer plus que ans
bénéficiant de certains produits bon
j'en ai nommé j'en ai nommé un
dernièrement la halle et des poufs dépôt
fiduciaire par exemple donc qui auraient
besoin de modifier la nature de leurs
avoirs pourrait éviter cette taxation
donc voilà il ya un projet qui
consistera et qui consista à identifier
les personnes qui se verrait pénalisés
par cette par cette réglementation et à
leur fournir un service donc qui sera
facturables pour ne pas avoir le subir
donc
imaginons s'il avait eu à payer 10 ils
n'auront finalement qu'à payer 5 mai à
la banque pas aux états et c'est
exactement ce ce ce type d'activités
auxquelles je me référais quand je
parlais de projets stratégiques et dodo
logique de contournement et de de saisie
de d'opportunités commerciales en
l'occurrence lorsque vous avez trouvé
refuge en france quelles ont été vos
démarches concrètes pour faire connaître
ces fichiers d'abord puisque un récent
rapport de l'assemblée nationale fait
état d'une certaine déconvenue de votre
part enfin vous en avez un peu parlé au
près après que la dnif vous orienter
vers le ministère de l'économie et des
finances quelles étaient les raisons de
cette déconvenue selon vous les avez
vous été protégé dans l'intervalle et
toujours à propos de l'assemblée
nationale il est indiqué que vous avez
pu regretter que l'exploitation
informatique n'est pas été aussi
approfondi qu'elle aurait pu qu'elle
aurait pu l'être ou dû l'être
est-ce que c'est selon vos exacte et
qu'elle lacunes ne peut-on identifier
sur ce sujet on est resté toujours dans
le sujet 1 depuis le début de la séance
maintenant ce que j'ai pu moi constaté
c'est que déjà au niveau réglementaire
on a un problème parce que si on a
besoin aujourd'hui de l'ancien d'alert
c'est qu'au niveau des témoins on n'a
pas une protection correspondance
correspondante ce qui nécessite c'était
moi et tant qu'on n'aura pas ça il y
aura un manque au niveau
démocratique et au niveau de la justice
maintenant quand donc j'ai eu à
réprouver c'est le terme et n'est pas
vraiment adapté je dirais que j'aurais
bien aimé pouvoir m'adresser directement
à la justice sans avoir besoin de passer
par une commission rogatoire
internationale
cela dit la france ne le permet pas
toujours pas aujourd'hui dire
qu'aujourd'hui si je me retrouvais en
suisse avec ces mêmes éléments de preuve
pour une banque dont la dangerosité est
révélé n'oublions pas que c'est la
banque la plus con damné de l'histoire
hsbc a déjà été condamné à hauteur de 1
9 milliard de dollars
donc malgré la dangerosité d'une banque
si aujourd'hui j'avais ces informations
à transmettre à la justice française je
ne pourrais pas le faire
ça me passait par justement le fait
d'être dans le cadre d'une enquête déjà
ouvertes
donc je me suis retrouvé dans les mains
de l'administration fiscale
probablement parce que en termes
judiciaires n'y avait en aucun cas il
n'y a toujours pas l'arsenal qui permet
de faire autrement
arsenal qui existent ne serait-ce qu'à
nos frontières il suffit d'aller en
espagne on aura un arsenal qui permet
donc de combler cette lacune que nous
avons ici
donc voilà ça c'est déjà pour les laits
je dirais les regret les la tristesse
que je peux avoir à constater et à
revenir sur cette partie de mon parcours
ensuite pour ce qui est des moyens pour
exploiter les données plus mieux
complètement de façon utile
et puis en plus proactive avec une
possibilité d'enclencher un mécanisme
qui nous permettra de rester au niveau
pas simplement de bénéficier d'une
connaissance
à un moment tu es mais aussi après de
garder et d'enrichir cette connaissance
donc tout ça c'est ce dont j'ai déjà
discuté à savoir ce qui est à notre
portée aujourd'hui c'est un potentiel
donc jeu
regrette que le précédent gouvernement
n'ait pas pris les mesures qu'il était à
même de pouvoir prendre et qu'il aurait
dû prendre et j'espère et je suis
optimiste sur que sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui grâce aussi à vous eh
bien on va tous ensemble arriver enfin à
proposer quelque chose quelque chose qui
fera que quand on se retrouvera ou quand
on aura l'occasion de faire le point sur
où on en est on pourra établir que des
avancées auront été effectués qu'on aura
franchi des pas décisifs
oui on a eu l'occasion d'auditions et
monsieur paris 10 l'an dernier directeur
à l'époque de la dgfip il nous avait dit
que il n'avait pas pu exploiter les
fichiers que pensez vous de cette
appréciation et velouté associés à ces
travaux avec à bercy enfin à la dg fille
de mr général alors par exemple lorsque
il n'y a pas plus tard que quelques
semaines j'ai géré eux j'ai recontacté
les personnes avec qui j'avais commencé
à travailler il y a de cela cinq ans au
niveau de la nef de la migration fiscale
et je leur ai posé une question j'ai dit
est ce qu'aujourd'hui si on reprenait
depuis le début cette aventure est-ce
que vous pensez que nous auriez ont
travaillé ensemble dans un hôtel sur
nice à une chambre d'hôtel pour laquelle
rien n'était prévu dans laquelle rien
n'était assurée ni en termes de sécurité
pour nos personnes pour nos personnes
nées en termes de sécurité sur les
protocoles d'analysé de traitement des
informations
imaginez vous imaginez vous traitez la
mémoire d'une banque dans une chambre
d'hôtel c'est ce qu'on a vécu les gens
courageux l'administration fiscale ont
participé à ça bien à leur dépend aussi
bien en encourant des risques et s'il
n'y avait pas eu derrière d'autres
mécanismes pour sécuriser cela moi même
je ne me serais pas soumis mais ça c'est
la responsabilité de qui en tout cas pas
des agents qui ont été soumis c'est au
dessus
que les moyens n'ont pas été réunies
pour traiter
le sujet à la mesure que le mériter vous
dites que nous n'avons pas en france et
moyens que semble-t-il les espagnols
auraient mais face à ce problème que
soulève tous tous cette affaire il ya
quand même de deux techniques
l'administration fiscale certes elle est
obligée de passer par la commission des
infractions fiscales ne peut déposer
plainte pour fraude fiscale et puis le
parquet peut parfaitement ouvrir
directement une enquête voir après
suscité une instruction pour blanchiment
de fraude fiscale
puis après lancer le processus d'
enquête classique avec des pouvoirs
des enquêteurs français qui ne sont
certainement pas moindres que ceux
espagnol je comprends mal votre réserve
là où votre critique du système j'allais
dire juridique
eh bien oui bien simplement d'expérience
par rapport à ce que j'ai pu j'ai pu le
vérifier moi-même lorsque je rentre en
contact avec la police judiciaire en
je suis à ce moment encore dans la
banque hsbc d'accord et bien ce qui ce
se qui s'opèrent c'est pas la mise à
disposition de la justice de ses preuves
c'est le fait qu'on me qu'on me fasse
qu'on me mette je dire en contact avec
les agents de la mission fiscale et
qu'on me dise nous ne pouvons pas
obtenir ne pourront pas utiliser de
façon judiciaire vos informations ne
pourront pas à tester leurs origines et
nous ne pourrons les utiliser qu'en
termes de renseignements donc moi je
vous fais tu as simplement de ce qui
sera établie par parler les agents de
l'administration qui ont eu en charge
nous rapporter ce que ce que vous
faisiez vérité je suis sûrement ça me
paraît très contestable je crains que
choix soit ailleurs
fraude fiscale
on considère que c'est l'administration
qui est compétente et pas le sauf si
l'administration saisi la justice
et il me semble que si vous permettez
non si vous permettez on est on est
avant même cette problématique on est
dans le fait que si moi je me présente à
vous avec une liste et je dis je suis
témoin de jeux des jeux je dirais je
vais dénoncer un certain nombre de faits
quand je suis témoin je vais danser
ensemble de faits bon bref j'aime lis je
l'écris je n'ai pas d'autres
responsabilités que ma parole par contre
si je vous fournit des preuves des
mondes preuve est que je ne peux pas
tester l'origine de ses preuves
vous pourrez être poursuivi pour recel
si ces éléments sont si vous utilisez un
matériel qui les volent et imaginons
vous est possible pour recel et c'est ça
qu'il faut modifier mais c'est
aujourd'hui
et moi je vous parle des liasses à 5 ans
et aujourd'hui encore avant que cette
modification soit acté nous serons dans
la même situation nous resterons dans
une situation bien pour poursuivre le
cheminement encore une fois je demandais
de rassembler vos souvenirs et je pense
que vous avez une excellente mémoire
époux voulu indiquer si des banques
françaises figuraient parmi les
personnes morales concernées par les
fameuses données puisque un rapport de
l'assemblée nationale site certaines
d'entre elles est ce que vous souvenez
de lors de leur identité même question
pour les entreprises non financières
il y avait il également des
personnalités connues éventuellement des
responsables politiques de premier plan
voilà la première question que je
voulais vous pose donc
vous allez comprendre toujours que mon
intérêt c'est de se ramener son
mécanisme rappeler que mon havre et
expertise elle est dans les mécanismes
les mécanismes d'adaptation en
l'occurrence de la banque
et c'est là où je vais pouvoir vraiment
contribué dans tout dans à la hauteur de
tout mon potentiel
par contre sur des données qui sont plus
du domaine des clients de la banque
des intermédiaires de la banque eh bien
ma contribution se limitera à quoi au
fait de rappeler que la banque
fonctionne de façon distribué avec une
myriade d'intermédiaire ce qui
nécessitera pour nous d'ailleurs de se
réunir à plusieurs de réunir non
seulement nos efforts les ford
différents ministères localement mais
aussi de se réunir entre états lorsque
donc vous me demandez si j'ai mémoire de
banque
je dirais c'est évident que ce qu'on
appellera le l'intermédiaire banking
c'est à dire le fait qu'une banques
détiennent de ses avoirs dans d'autres
banques est le mécanisme qui permet
d'établir un maillage entre toutes
entre une multitude une myriade d'autres
institutions financières
et ça s'est assuré que même sans
regarder même sans avoir jamais
construite a aucune liste ce n'est il
est exclu d'imaginer que donc cette
banque donc suisse n'est pas de comptes
ne soient pas en relation avec des
banques françaises donc et c'est ça le
plus important c'est patent forcément
que les banques françaises soient
clients de cette banque
mais plus que les banques françaises
aient comme client cette banque qui peut
présenter aussi donc des risques pour
nous
des éléments qui nous faudra vigiles et
est surveillé de près donc moi ce que je
pense et que la dangerosité que je vois
et l'important qu'il y a dans la
connaissance des relations qui existent
entre des banques françaises et des
banques suisses résident dans
la présence de compte dans chacune de
ces entités de kant de compte qu'on
appellera miroir ou nostro lorho et ce
sont ces maillage effectivement qu'ils
sont qui existent et qui sont répartis
entre plusieurs banques donc vous pouvez
avoir une banque par exemple espagnol
qui aura un combat une banque française
et suisse et qui fera que la banque
française sans avoir même de comptes
déclarés en suisse pourra bénéficier
d'un circuit qui qui finira en suisse
donc les ce ne sera pas forcément les
clients directs simplement qu'ils
présenteront des intérêts mais
évidemment vous allez avoir des banques
françaises qui directement ou en
relation avec les banques suisses et
sept banques là en l'occurrence vous
avez différentes façons de réaliser ou
de concrétiser les relations qui
existent rond entre banques
donc les clés les comptes et les
transactions nous avons aussi les
transactions qui transiteront par
différentes banques pour différents
intermédiaires
donc c'est tout ce maillage c'est toute
cette complexité des moyens de
communication aujourd'hui et des moyens
d'euros de relations et des relations
existantes qui qui pose le niveau du
défi et effectivement les banques
présentes ce ce problème alors après
quand ça nous ramène aux noms propres au
nom par exemple de personnalités ou ou
deux ministres il faut pas présumer que
que je dirais un politique soit plus
bête qu'un autre il ne va pas forcément
déclarer son compte en nom propre
quand nous avons tous les moyens
d'intermédiation qui vous permettront
par exemple de bénéficier de certains ce
service de certaines aides
c'est un voyage peut-être en bref quand
vous voyez tous les moyens qui vous
permettront de re et d'être rétribué de
façon indirecte et bien vous allez
comprendre qu'il ne va pas qui n'a aucun
intérêt à vous exposer directement à
détenir des biens en suisse donc plus
vous allez être au fait de ces
intermédiation mieux vous allez
connaître ses mécanismes et moins vous
allez vous exposez au fait de détenir un
compte directement ce sera d'entrer
dedans des mesures vraiment très infime
que l'on va retrouver des gens exposés
directement
est-ce qu'il ya les comptes
d'entreprises grosses entreprises
notamment qui ont des qui sont concernés
par cette et hsbc private banking qui
peut paraître surprenant est ce que vous
confirmez votre analyse on est
évidemment évidemment là si vous voyez
par exemple on va revenir sur les
logiques d'évitement vous avez hsbc qui
au luxembourg voyant le vent tourner au
niveau des noms avec la fadq a au nom
des personnes qui déclarent leur nom et
bien va céder ses activités de banque
privée au luxembourg pour se concentrer
sur la gestion des clients qui sont
corporate c'est à dire la partie des
entreprises donc cesser la réponse vous
voyez que aujourd'hui effectivement le
le le secteur économique va se
réorienter vers des entreprises par vers
des intermédiaires des éléments
d'intermédiation par rapport au nom
personnel aux personnes physiques
notre collègue christian kert rapporteur
de la commission à l'assemblée nationale
a fait un travail de plusieurs mois sur
la liste hsbc et faisait état dans la
presse récemment de nombreux salariés
des chaises baissé plus d'une centaine
de mémoire dont il semblerait à
l'évidence qu'ils aient des prête-noms
pour d'autres est ce que vous confirmez
cet état de fait
moi encore une fois chaque cas mérite et
nécessitent d'être
analyser de façon conséquente quand vous
trouvez des employés qui ont des droits
les droits par exemple qui peut être de
droit de regard de signature peut-être
mais à voir il faudra connaître la
nature du compte est la raison pour
laquelle sont détenus ou son associé au
niveau de certains droits ses comptes
s'il s'agit imaginé d'un fonds de
pension et que l'employée a aussi la
gestion de ce fonds de pension il se
verra associés à ce compte bancaire sans
que les avoirs soient réellement à lui
alors si vous parlez de milliers
d'employés bon ça pourrait être
il sera possible que bon on aura en tout
cas une diversité de cas de figure
maintenant je dirais ma connaissance et
que la banque fonctionne par
cloisonnement et va éviter de s'exposer
directement je vous dis c'est la logique
de l'évitement
alors ça me semble quand même voilà sa
semaine ça m'interpelle
le fait de penser que des milliers
d'employés soit prête noms dans cette
banque faudrait voir de plus près je
n'ai pas d'éléments aujourd'hui pour
l'établir clairement après c'est vrai
que dans quelques mois peut-être que je
pourrais vous répondre différemment
qu'est ce qui vous a amené à fuir vers
l'espagne et un moment donné
donc quand quand donc les élections
présidentielles ont permis si hollande
donc de devenir président le vent a
changé les la demande d'entraidé
judiciaire formulée par l'amérique qui
avait été étouffé qui avait été refusée
pendant de nombreux mois voire des
années repart ça veut dire quelques
semaines simplement quelques semaines
après l'élection
ce françois hollande tant que président
reprend la collaboration judiciaire avec
l'amérique des états unis et à ce titre
je suis entendu procureur américain à
paris au niveau de la section de
recherche d'argent au national et on
indique donc que et bien malheureusement
les mesures ne sont pas à même d'être
prise
je dirais on avance mais a minima c'est
à dire que ils n'auront qu'une partie
des des informations ils ont eu qu'une
partie de l'aide qu'il pouvait espérer
de la justice française à son état en ce
moment et c'est pas du domaine de
l'exécutif ces deux domaines de
magistrats à cette époque qu'est ce qui
sent qu est ce qu il en résulte moi je
me retrouve donc à nouveau exposé sans
avoir de mesures de protection adéquates
et et les mêmes personnes qui m'avaient
aidé à sécuriser les preuves pour
qu'elles puissent être transmises à la
justice
ces mêmes personnes mort à 52 options
nous propose cette option est celle qui
me semblent malgré tout pas la moins
dangereuse mais préférable par rapport à
mes convictions et à mon combat c'est de
me rendre en espagne
alors je sais que
je vais être emprisonnés mais il faut
reconnaître bon dans certaines mesures
qui étaient qui sont avérés bien autre
que celle espérée
et donc voilà je sais pour fuir
certaines menaces pour fuir les risques
inhérents au fait que d'un côté
l'entr'aide reprend d'un autre côté
peut-être que la lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale l'opacité financière va
reprendre et que pendant le temps
qu'elle reprenne moi je ne serai pas
n'étant pas protégés je serai exposés
donc c'est dans cette condition
dans ces conditions dans ce contexte que
je prends la décision effectivement de
me rendre en espagne
votre commentaire sur le ce qui vient
d'arriver à monsieur pierre condamin
gerbier votre collègue qui a été
auditionnée ici même le 12 juin dernier
et donc les autorités suisses viennent
de l'incarcérer c'est bien cela ces
mesures voilà la justice s'empare de son
cas quel est votre commentaire sur cette
situation
mon commentaire c'est que
bon je ne connais pas déjà cette
personne mais ce qui est certain c'est
que toute personne qui participe à la
justice donc jusqu'à preuve du contraire
il s'est présenté à la justice
il est devenu un témoin pour des
enquêtes en cours au niveau de la
justice française
et qu'est ce que je vois c'est couper
l'herbe coupée lab sur le pied de la
justice française donc quelle est la
démarche quel est le fond de cette
démarche de la justice suisse dans ce
dossier
c'est vraiment empêcher une instruction
qui est en développement sur le
territoire français ça c'est factuel et
indépendant de la personne moi je ne
peux pas je ne connais pas même la
nature des informations qu'il a
transmise le témoignage qu'il a à
transmettre
mais je sais que ça de témoin et en tant
que témoin dans une procédure française
je pense que n'étant pas en guerre avec
la suisse on pourrait s'attendre à une
meilleure collaboration des justice
mettez marc collat sur le départ en
espagne
vous indiquez que ayant pris conscience
avec la collaboration franco usa que
vous ne seriez pas même en france
d'avoir toutes les garanties d'aller le
plus loin possible dans l'exploitation
de ce que vous avez observé
vous mettez en exergue la folle al
danger que ça pourrait avoir pour vous
mais ce qu'il ya aussi un le fait que la
justice espagnole et les mécanismes de
travail de l'espagne vous permettait de
continuer un travail d'investigation et
d'aller vers un traitement judiciaire
des choses ou est-ce que c'était
uniquement lié aux menaces que vous
sentiez potentiellement sur vous
évidemment plusieurs plusieurs
paramètres ont influé mon choix parmi
les paramètres je pourrais simplement
constater que lorsque fut nommé donc au
ministère du budget monsieur cahuzac
pour moi la la tournure des événements
ne semblait pas tout à fait favorable ne
serait-ce que sur cet axe maintenant il
y en a d'autres il ya effectivement le
fait qu' un certain nombre de démarches
avec les informations à minima avait été
menée en espagne avec succès des
personnes de plus haut niveau il faut
rappeler que monsieur bottines donc est
vraiment le représentant de la plus
puissante banque européenne à ce jour et
à cette ander avait été reconnu coupable
donc l'évasion pour plusieurs centaines
de millions d'euros
donc il fallait comprendre il fallait
resitué fort et aujourd'hui c'est même
l'occasion aussi d'insister là dessus
vous avez des dirigeants au plus haut
niveau des plus grandes instances
bancaires européennes qui pratiquent
l'évasion fiscale déjà donc ça ça a été
effectué c'est un résultat acquis en
espagne par l'espagne donc c'est un des
facteurs des paramètres qui a influé
dans mon choix
ensuite bon bain
pour m
les énumérer il y aura effectivement le
fait que je m'attendais pas non plus a
passé cinq mois en prison quand on sait
que dans le cas je vous ai parlé des
frères elmaleh qui s'agit quand même de
blanchiment d'argent de narcotrafiquants
et bien la personne était condamné à six
mois de prison
donc je sais pas combien de mois leur a
fait mais donc voilà on attend quel pays
vous avez été emprisonnés en espagne en
espagne en espagne sous pourquoi sur à
la demande de la banque de la chaise b
c'est qui qui a demandé donc par
l'interpol à ce que donc je soit extradé
vers vers la suisse pour des motifs là
aussi on y revenait aussi c'est une
parenthèse c'est que si vous le
permettez bien je pourrais faire
faut voir qu'on a prétexté à la justice
suisse entre autres d'autres mensonges
et que je n'avais pas que je n'avais pas
été disponible pour participer à leur
enquête qui s'était déroulé déjà depuis
cinq ans sachant qu'ils avaient toujours
eu mon adresse mon téléphone personnel
pour nous joindre à tout instant par mon
intermédiaire de mes avocats qui m'avait
convié à une visite en février 2012 sur
territoire suisse où je m'étais rendu
donc quand on voit tous ces éléments et
quand on réalise donc que il s'adresse à
une autre justice en prétextant que déjà
ils avaient besoin de m'extrader parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas possible de rentrer
en contact avec moi pour faire
progresser l'enquêté
on voit bien dans quel contexte on se
situe on voit bien quelle est la gravité
la gravité de la situation
quand on arrive à ce que des des
représentants d'une justice se comporte
de cette façon
donc bon au résultat voilà je me suis
retrouvé emprisonné pour ces motifs dans
un cadre où la justice espagnole
finalement a rempli son rôle et dans
tout l'est dans tous les axes par
rapport à ses engagements elle pour le
elle a rempli ses engagements européens
et internationaux
et elle a aussi rempli son rôle en me
permettant d'aider la justice dans le
cadre donc du parquet anticorruption
donc en y allant je n'étais pas assuré
de pouvoir amener ma contribution aussi
à au parquet anti corruption il
s'avérait que ce fut possible et j'en
suis ravi bon le coup a été rude
le cours est rude mais mais c'est ainsi
c'est fait c'est effectivement au regard
donc de tous est tout ce contexte de ce
poids il faut comprendre que aujourd'hui
je reprends je représente une menace
grande menace par rapport à quoi
par rapport au bien le plus précieux de
la plupart de ces banques privées qui
est leur réputation
donc ma simple personne le simple fait
que vous me receviez ici
le simple fait que ça se compte que ça
se continue par la suite qu'on
maintienne la pression et qu'on engage
des moyens pour lutter et bien va
affaiblir naturellement ses activités
gérées qui sont répréhensibles vis-à-vis
de nos intérêts donc c'est tout cet
c'est tout cette fois c'est tout ce
poids c'est tout ce potentiel là qui a
fait qu'à un moment donné et l'a fallu
que je pense à sécuriser la personne
quelques dernières questions sur les
approchons de leurs de l'audition
suivante je n'aurais pas prendre de
retard dont vous venez en gros nous
expliquer que l'exploitation totale et
intégrale de la liste de fin du fichier
n'a pas été accompli que si j'ai bien
compris d'un système des systèmes
d'information disponible sur la banque
est ce que vous y travaillez encore
aujourd'hui avec excuse d'abord vous
avez vous y avez travaillé avec d'autres
pays je pense à la grèce le royaume uni
par exemple est ce que vous y travaillez
encore aujourd'hui à l'exploitation de
ces systèmes
et pensez vous qu'il faille imaginons
une autorité indépendante une équipe
d'experts indépendant et transparent qui
aurait la tâche de travailler jusqu'aux
fonde justement de l'installation de ces
systèmes est ce que ce serait utile
nécessaire et
notamment du point de vue de l'intégrité
de la liste parce que la question est
revenue à plusieurs reprises dès
l'audition ici du procureur de
montgolfier qui se posaient la question
comme beaucoup d'autres personnes
donc pensez vous cette intégrité et été
préservé parce que la liste a quand même
circuler entre beaucoup de mains depuis
sa transmission jusqu'à l'exploitation
aujourd'hui et pour la suite voilà donc
qu'est ce qui a pu se passer entre deux
pensez vous que l'intégrité de sept de
ses fichiers et était vraiment respectée
et dernière question plus personnelle
vous l'avez évoqué vous parlez de
menaces à votre endroit
de quel type de menaces d'abord et de la
part de qui proviennent telles données
ce qui est essentiel de bien comprendre
aujourd'hui nous sommes en mesure
d'assurer l'intégrité des données et
d'assurer qu'elles auront été ou pas
tronqué par telle ou telle
administration
pourquoi parce que par le par le même
mécanisme que les informations auront
été en disponibles et mis dans les mains
de la justice française les mêmes
informations qui ont été transmises à la
justice française ont été transmises à
la justice espagnole ce qui permettra
donc de les comparer et d'établir qu'il
n'ya pas d'altération qu'il n'y a pas eu
de modification de saisir la justice
suisse également justice us aussi donc
on aura déjà la possibilité d'assurer
qu'il n'y a pas eu d'altération mais là
je vous dis je je préfère donc me
recentrer sur le fait que déjà en france
et en espagne avant même l'acceptation
de la collaboration judiciaire
les deux entités compte ne possédez les
informations des fausses informations
identiques donc le rapprochement pourra
être effectuée pour a levé le doute levé
le doute aussi sur quoi / / / justement
des informations qu'on était qu'on était
je dirais tronquée qui ont été dévoyés
sur le fait que des fichiers ont été
modifiés un rapport de la justice
suisse qui disait qui révélait que les
données aux des fichiers auraient été
altérée et là il faut bien comprendre la
différence qu'il ya entre l'intégrité
l'identité matériel est logique d'un
d'une information si vous avez un film
une vidéo ce que vous le copier vous
aurez sur cette copie la préservation de
l'intégrité logique de ces informations
par contre physiquement effectivement
non ce ne sera pas le même physique donc
ce qu avait soulevé les autorités
suisses avaient été justement une
modification en termes physiques sur 7
un fichier qui n'ont jamais été exploité
jusqu'ici de surcroît mais par contre
ces altérations physiques qui pouvait
rien révélé peut-être ne serait-ce
qu'une copine ne permet tait en aucun
cas d'attester d'une altération logique
donc ça aussi c'est une notion
importante qu'il convient de partager
aujourd'hui ensuite
donc vous avez posé un certain nombre de
questions il y avait aussi donc la
possibilité donc poursuivre la lutte ben
oui je le répète la possibilité de
poursuivre la lutte
elles existent d'exploiter ces
informations elle existe est d'aller
au-delà c'est à dire ces informations
ont surtout à mon sens l'intérêt de
révéler la dynamique cité de la banque
de la dce de la diversité des outils
dont elle dispose pour pouvoir justement
contourner les réglementations mais donc
faisant état de cela il s'agit pas de
s'arrêter à cela seul
il s'agit donc de mettre en place les
mécanismes qui vont nous permettre de
faire face à cela et je suis je suis
optimiste sur le fait qu'on y arrive et
je sais que on est déjà en contact pour
essayer que tous ensemble avec ma
contribution
on arrive justement à constituer quelque
chose d'efficace et de correspondants
aux enjeux enfin pour ma menace donc
elle et elle est aussi tributaire de
cela c'est à dire que ayant un
gouvernement qui veulent ou du thé qui
cherche réellement à lutter contre
l'évasion fiscale contre la l'opacité
financière
et bien en étant un acteur qui va
permettre justement de donner un
avantage dans cette lutte qui représente
un avantage dans cette lutte tant que je
resterai un élément assez unique assez
assez marginal jeux seraient exposées à
un risque et donc dès que l'on rentrera
dans une démarche qui sera plus étatique
où on aura des structures correspondante
conséquente alors là les risques sur la
personne seront diminués évidemment je
pouvais rester peut-être emblématique
sur certains points parce que justement
peut-être que si je me projette avec
optimisme je serai peut-être un des
éléments déterminants dans cette
constitution d'une force de défense mais
malgré tout je dirais le risque sera
moindre parce que nous serons sur un
pied qui sera plus d'égalité et je ne
représente pas la marginalité qui risque
d'être le déclenchement à quoi deux d'un
mécanisme de défense est-ce que vous
avez été approché et je conclurai là
dessus par les autorités supervision
françaises l'autorité de contrôle
prudentiel et l'autorité des marchés
financiers je n'ai jusqu'à mon retour
d'espagne
la seule et unique personne en dehors de
la migration fiscale la nef et la
justice qui m'apporte qui m'a approché
seule autorité qui m'a approché a été
arnaud montebourg point barre
seule personne qui a donc en terme
d'autorité qui a qui s'est intéressé à
ce qui se passait dans le fond a été
monsieur arnaud de montebourg donc que
je n'étais je n'ai jusqu'ici pas encore
été approché par toute autre entité
prudentielles bien nous qui fassions
merci beaucoup pour cette audition qui
se termine